Donald Trump just capped off a
phenomenal week for his presidency and
the American people of course he had the
signing of the USMC a remarkable
private-sector jobs numbers a stock
market that's shaken off to even the
coronavirus and the cherry on top is
Sean just mentioned his acquittal on
both articles of impeachment earlier
today now it's largely because of these
continued successes that President Trump
has exposed the frauds on the left they
just can't take it anymore and one in
particular on the right let's start with
Nancy Pelosi last night she showed the
world who she really is
a woman left with little else but her
own sour puss facial expression and a
paper ripping stunt she let her anger
get the best of her and her white suit
didn't make her look any more angelic it
was the color of surrender
now she wasn't the only person acting
out
Utah's junior senator reminded us of why
he couldn't connect with most regular
working-class people they don't like
politicians who claim to be
holier-than-thou when they're really
just sticking a shiv in your back but my
promise before God to apply impartial
justice required that I put my personal
feelings and political biases aside were
I to ignore the evidence that has been
presented it would I fear expose my
character to history's rebuke its
exposed it alright he's the ultimate
selfish preening self-centered
politician he has good hair and a sort
of okay singing voice a shock that
didn't work well he should try out for
the masked singer maybe when he loses
reelection well he wanted desperately to
be Trump's Secretary of State and then
he casts this futile pointless vote to
convict him in order to show that he's a
man of principle unlike all these other
Republicans it's called payback but if
he were up for re-election this year the
people of Utah would have their own
payback against him because they were
defrauded by Romney for when he had to
choose he chose Schumer and Kamala over
common sense and conservatism if you're
one of Romney's constituents in Utah
you're out of luck if you're a
businessman in need of a regulation
reexamined don't bother calling his
office he has no power anymore if he
even attends the Republican convention
at all he's gonna get booed many of his
colleagues will freeze him out few will
trust him again and could you blame him
and let's not forget what the Democrats
and media said about him in 2012 this is
insulting binders full of women mitt
kenneled his Irish Setter and strapped
into the roof
this car during a road trip no your dog
to your car chance what Mitt Romney has
in common with the KKK they just had
Nick Romney's plans to expand one of his
homes by adding a car elevator the
elitism that's that's what it's about
who can you know feel anything in common
with Mitt Romney well back then there
were only a few of us on TV and radio
who defended you met and we did this
because we thought you'd be better for
America and the way you repay millions
of people the millions who did vote for
you in 2012 is to throw in with the very
people who don't share our goals who
hate us and by the way who still hate
you does he not see what Adam Schiff and
Pelosi and Feinstein have done to let's
say California and does he not know if
they got real power then do to Salt Lake
City what they've done to San Francisco
will he have the courage to have a real
town hall to defend this vote he
couldn't even get simple facts right
while debating Obama it was not a
spontaneous demonstration is that what
you're saying please proceed governor I
want to make sure we get that for the
record because it took the president 14
days before he called the attack in
Benghazi an act of terror yet the
transfer it he did in fact sir so let me
let me call it an act he did call it an
act of terror Romney couldn't even have
a comeback to Candy Crowley's
coordinated response to the Obama that's
all I told you all you needed to know
all of this is a good reminder it's kind
of pile on him for the sake of piling on
him but we have to learn from all of
this
this entire impeachment debacle what a
disaster the GOP establishment was for
America think about it
Mitt Romney is the establishment they
were wrong on China they were wrong on
Iraq they were wrong on immigration
wrong on the housing bubble wrong on the
bailouts wrong on things like Harriet
Miers and David Souter for the GOP
establishment it was always about what
was good for them personally or their
conscience or wall street not what was
what was
good for the average American for a few
brief shining moments in 2008 and 2012
some of us thought that Romney had a
solid core boy did he fool us he was a
Massachusetts liberal in 1994 when he
ran against Ted Kennedy for the Senate
then he moved a bit to the right when he
ran for governor then he claimed he was
a full-blown conservative when he first
ran for president in 2008 and now like
all the other bitter never Trump errs
he'd rather see the entire American
economy go down the drain then give
Trump a victory first I do want to
salute Mitt Romney the verdict of
history is gonna be on Mitt Romney's
side they seem to be reaching for the
ghost of John McCain he's changed his
place in history but that was a real act
of courage Mitt Romney give me hope for
the future mitt he made your stand now
she should resign you committed a fraud
and the people of Utah on the Republican
Party on the Constitution and have
thoroughly embarrassed yourself
Boehner retired Ryan left Washington
Cantor was bounced out of office
they just weren't in sync with the
priorities of most American Republican
voters and neither are you
Utah does not need someone who doesn't
get his phone calls returned they need
an actual functioning senator and Mike
Lee can't do everything
folks are supposed to enter politics to
advance policies that improve the lives
of everyday Americans that's what Trump
did and his policies are working Romney
apparently went into politics because of
his dad or because he wanted everyone to
think he was a good person he never
actually wins arguments or persuades
anyone of anything and at the end of the
day one man was trying to impress the
elites in Washington today and the guy
in the Oval Office was not all along he
was just trying to make America greater
and he has Romney I hope enjoys his
brief moment in the Sun while he's
lauded by the very people who spent the
last 20 years attacking him because in a
few weeks the phone will stop ringing
he'll be lucky lucky to get
booked on Chris Cuomo show we won't ever
forget Utah should never forget and if I
have to move there to run against him in
four and a half years I will I do like
that Park City skiing in the summer
hiking and that's the angle Lindsey
Graham will join us in a few minutes to
talk about the president's acquittal and
Romney's petulance but first old man's
little outburst last night was the
former House Speaker Newt Gingrich led
to calling her to be censured and
professor Jonathan Turley the
constitutional scholar who voted for
Hillary Clinton is calling Pelosi to
apologize and change her conduct or
resign